today on code vlogs episode 14
we're going to be making a test scene
and blender to import and this scene is
going to have multiple models multiple
textures
and we're also going to put some
identifiers for where things should be
just so that we can test that that's
where they are
uh
yeah so that's where we're at right now
more on this later
all right just exporting these
colors as textures here and we should be
able to load this in i'm not going to
texture this text at first
because i wanted to just get the default
colors which should work and we will
find that out the fault color in the
engine is a bit of a gray
which is defined in the default shaders
somewhere
yeah
well the diffuse should be reddish in
color if it doesn't have a texture lit
stuff should be
oh i don't know what color actually the
list was gonna be i think it's grayish
it was whatever the flashlight was
before we added textures last episode so
we're gonna export this do a little
testing with it see if everything comes
in properly see if it reads the textures
properly and this will be a good little
benchmark to have so we're actually
going to export this as a benchmark
edit or render
whereas nevermind export i mean
and we can try different formats too to
make sure they're all handled okay
because if we export this
well fbx has the option of baking
textures i don't know if this works
properly in blender but obj's are pretty
great for non-animated stuff and colada
seems to be
the most open for now
gltf is like the opengl vulcan standard
so i might use those if i'm not going to
do directx of course
the engine still is on opengl but there
is the intention of
putting in a vulcan renderer before too
long
and uh well there's just so much for one
person to do as you guys probably are
starting to notice here
uh in a game engine so i would very much
love to have a teammate at some point um
we'll see if that happens if you wish to
apply join the discord say i want to
work on it or something or just start
making pool requests because this is
completely free and open source in case
you haven't noticed
and now at this point we are stepping
through the model loader and finding out
exactly what happens on these failed
loads
so that's what i'm going to be doing for
a while until i come across something
that seems like it's causing the problem
now this is often the most time
consuming part of programming you have
an idea and things are going well
everything's coming together quickly and
that's always like the fun part but the
reality is at some point
especially when you're doing complicated
things you're going to run into a
situation where
things aren't going as expected and you
have to step through the code very
carefully and hope that something pops
out that's uh the issue of your problem
of course it's great to have an idea of
where to look and if you go into debug
mode and run it in debug mode you should
get info about all your variables so in
something like visual studio you can
hover over them there's ways to do this
in gdb
as well if you're using only command
line but it is not as beginner friendly
as pressing f11 graph 10 to step to your
code i don't want to start a tutorial on
that maybe maybe it deserves itself but
uh the point is
this is what you end up spending a lot
of time doing and that's what i'll be
doing for the foreseeable future
until this gets straightened out and i
thought i'd just hit record and put that
little thing out there because it is uh
the reality of things that's why they
pay us the big bucks
okay and i've stepped a bunch now and
i'm at that magical point where one of
my models i know for sure is loading the
texture wrong so it's on this particular
iteration that i'm looking for
exactly what's happening at that texture
load that is in theory failing so i'm
going to skip down a little bit hit
continue because i want to go over all
the vertices and meshes quickly actually
i kind of need to know is it doing the
textures right and
some stuff like that so i'm going to
look at these vertices and i should be
able to do that by just hovering over oh
size zero
size zero okay maybe this is part of the
issue uh maybe i'm not at the point i
thought it was
let's see the mesh that we're processing
says has 1500 vertices
so we should be going through all those
we should be going through all the faces
as some bones okay maybe i'm not i
thought i was but uh yeah i thought i
was on the hair of that you know the guy
with the weird hair but uh maybe not so
this is the reality of debugging who
knows how long i'll be doing this but
hopefully i'll have it straightened out
before too long because i would like to
continue on with what the other stuff i
have planned
also
this is not a bad thing some people get
to this step and they just like get
really frustrated and basically quit
but here's the kicker
this is where you really learn when you
start digging in like this and analyzing
the data things will click that have
never clicked before and if you just
refuse to do this step you have no way
of ever getting that stuff and you're
doing yourself a disservice so don't be
afraid to get in and start debugging
it's incredibly valuable
in more ways than you'd ever imagine
yeah it's always touted as uh it's super
painful uh it's the worst but it's
growth this is growth
i did say at some point that i keep it
real with these code vlogs and that
they'd be pretty raw
it's about as real as it gets
it's not something i would typically
show off or ever make a video about
usually you can make videos about their
coding i swear i'm just going through
these vertices endlessly okay yeah
usually when people make videos about
their coding they might give you a quick
blurb of oh i spent two hours debugging
this and then they'll show you the cool
result and that's the video
and you get the impression that's hard
but you don't quite understand how they
solved it
or and stuff like that so i'm trying to
kind of show some of that
okay and i just stepped through some
debugging and i didn't see it but i'm
trying to resolve this guy's hair
clearly his hair oh it looks grayish
that's just the default shader color i
believe so it should appear as
well the color of his eyebrows and
eyelashes i think they're kind of like a
dark brown auburn color so that's what
we should be seeing and uh
i believe it's from the same texture
that's on the right to the rest of his
body so
something's not quite that with that and
yes we do have some new scene elements
it was just testing out multi objects
with textures and those seem to work
okay as objs
uh for example this ground has
the texture each of these has a texture
these primitives and they're all part of
the same object so it does work
multi-texturing multiple different
textures on multiple different objects
in one scene and loaded all the in the
same go but for some reason on this guy
it's weird now he is a colada file
and this guy is a i think he's an fbx he
might be a collado file too
and she is an fbx with all embedded
textures so embedded textures are okay
now uh yeah still still haven't got to
that part i'm trying to get this texture
part understood first but yeah just to
visually show what i'm looking for i'm
looking for where his hair is loading
and what it's actually doing why it's
not showing correctly because it's a bit
of a mystery as it works on some objects
but not others so we're going to keep
stepping through it
one of the things i have noticed about
this model is it has a
gazillion blank nodes i don't know why
it has so many blank nodes
but that's something we're going gonna
have to figure out
so
maybe well
maybe it's not an issue because it's
designed to handle them
however maybe i've got some case in
there that i'm not aware of where if
there's too many blank nose or something
it starts to do something different so
yeah we're going to be walking through
this for a while as far as i know
now another thing i like to do when i'm
in the middle of all this is just
kind of uh
you know if you're not sure if it's
exactly the model maybe the model's
messed up launch another game engine
launch unity launch unreal launch good
doe and try importing your model in
there and see how that goes for example
uh
some random test scene
and if i go to that model that i was
working on that is acting weird
let me find him here it's in this one
this one and it's walking this guy i
don't have any software that opens it on
my computer and it looks like i can't
just drag it in but maybe i can drag it
in down here
we'll see
maybe it'll give me okay failed reimport
okay looks like i have walking in here
twice that's fine i don't necessarily
want that i just want the
okay so it didn't bring it in at all it
looks like it only tried to bring in the
animations
i think
but i want the actual model data so
what's going on there let's try this guy
failed to import so
what
so i guess unreal doesn't support colada
files uh that seems strange to me they
are one of the largest biggest engines
why wouldn't they support one of the
the most commonly used formats i have no
clue this is news to me so maybe we'll
try
okay i could try the other engines see
what it does in there but now i'm
wondering and i'm asking the question
why does unreal not support colada that
seems strange maybe i shouldn't support
colada either but i'd like to do my own
research and find that answer for myself
rather than just making assumptions
but you can see here i have added the
other model in here the one that's not
loading correctly for me as an fbx well
it loads correctly
when not animated but as you can see
she's working okay here and animations
work okay here too so i know that this
model is pretty good but what's going on
with that colada file
so here i've loaded up unity and we're
going to try these same models see what
they do in here start with the walking
see what it lets us do
hold on it brings in it looks like a
model
well he's
absolutely massive
so unity does bring it in and it looks
like he's partially walking already
don't don't ask me why this is so huge i
don't know it's just like that i guess
um
i don't know if there's anything else
relevant here
does he have his animations ready to go
does he have his textures
doesn't look like it
looks like okay but it does do something
that looks like it might be pretty
important for me to realize he is in
separate parts i can click his leg
sections looks like
let's see here i can click his torso so
this would explain
maybe all the different okay i do see
some bones here too
and it looks like there's different
parts of this mesh there we go master
there's a shoe mesh there's a pants mesh
so this is why in my loader is flipping
through so many things there's a shirt
so there's a lot of different meshes on
this model and
it looks like my engine is doing a lot
of the stuff fine speed up this camera
like it's
it's handling all the meshes on the
hands the shirt fine it's just the hair
that gets different so what's going on
there maybe we can select his hair looks
like it's part of his spine
uh
can we set this to rendered or something
i don't know this this clearly isn't
getting the textures
on this particular thing i don't know
why i guess i'd have to bring it in
manually maybe i'll do that real quick
so i've got it in
let's see here
textures i believe it's this one is his
diffuse so maybe we'll try
to click this guy and just give him
can i click like this may just the guy
in general i don't want to i guess i got
to go over here and do it here he is
and
so this is a great way
to quickly analyze what's actually going
on with your model it's just bring it in
somewhere where it's going to tell you
more details basically that way you
don't have to specifically write a bunch
of little test code to say this stuff
this can save you a lot of time because
you're not going to necessarily want to
have to rewrite stuff just
to figure out things that can be
answered quickly elsewhere so how do we
add a texture to this guy let's find out
looks like at the root level we don't
have much and it looks like all these
parts are separated
so what what do i do here i i don't i
don't even know honestly i thought i'd
be able to bring in textures somewhere
but oh here's materials do i have that
on the root level no there's no
materials on the root level so i guess i
gotta custom assign each one
but i'm not seeing even where i'm
supposed to bring in the texture on here
so
i don't know i'm not i'm not a unity
user in general i use it kind of for
little tests and stuff but i don't build
games with it
so there's probably a lot i don't know
but material size one element
character body so i guess that this
should instead go to
this thing
what do i need to do do i need to make a
material out of it
it's not really what i wanted to do
there
so i'm guessing there's some way to make
a material here
and now this is just becoming a live
cast
new material
can we put this on it can we say hey use
this image
maybe we do it as the alpedo there yeah
there we go and now we should be able to
click this guy
and give his individual parts
some materials i think
that was his belt let's see if his belt
looks normal you can't even see his belt
his belt's under his shirt how do you
fly around in unity i don't know it's
really weird like i was doing it some
but it doesn't seem
to work like you would think okay so his
belt's got textures let's try adding his
shirt so it should just be the same one
i think it's just reusing a single
diffuse so let's bring this on there
let's go to let's go to his hair now his
hair wait
i click his hair if i didn't click his
hair so he's got a hair
set there
but if i bring in the diffuse
well that's exactly what i'm seeing in
my engine so
well on the animated one but so maybe
there is another texture that goes with
this model entirely now we can have a
look at this texture i know it looks so
strange but i don't see any place here
where it's necessarily the hair so maybe
yeah don't add me so maybe it is uh
weird look at these hands too so funny
the stuff of [ __ ]
we got shoes we got pants maybe this
here is the hair that looks more like a
belt or something maybe that's his belt
so would his hair be up here
i don't know if that's
that dark space is supposed to be his
hair or not i can't tell what about this
what's this down here
i don't know but clearly that's not
right that's uh so another thing we can
do is we can go back to where we got
this model which was from mixamo.com
super awesome
place and we can load up this original
model and you can see
it took a moment to load his hair there
but yeah he's got the hair texture that
you would expect to see so is that
coming from a special texture what we
can do here is just go ahead and
redownload it has something that's going
to bring well it's fbx or colada i was
doing it clotta
now fbx will save all the textures
internally so that might actually be
better fbx for unity there's the colada
again okay so
uh i'm going to download it as a clot
again and i'm going to unzip it and see
what kind of textures come with it
because i don't know where i put those i
might have deleted them or something
there we go we're getting it right here
showing folder there it is my phone's
ringing all right so we got it unzipped
and if we take a look at the textures in
here we have a diffuse glossy normal
specular ah and this diffuse this looks
like it's the one that has the hair now
i i'm pretty sure that i didn't bring
this in so it's probably just not
finding it
in that case i should be able to just
copy this over
into my textures
here's my textures
and now it should find it
so it's two diffuse textures i'm not
sure if my engine actually handles
multiple diffuse pretty it should it
should just look for this one for that
mesh now it should find it so yeah i
deleted like the normal specular for now
i was going to bring back in later but i
did not realize that there was also a
hair diffuse so that explains a lot
and now that that is in the proper
folder
let's go ahead
and just run our engine again i'm going
to put it in release
and i'm going to disable all breakpoints
and just hit play and let it do its
thing and let's see what we get let's
see if his hair looks right and lo and
behold his hair is actually fine that is
not a problem with my model loader after
all
even on the animated model his hair
looks fine so the model loader's fine
error was in user
not bringing in the texture that i
needed so
eventually with the debugging i would
have noticed that but when i was
flipping to that debugging
the only things i really noticed was
that well basically that there are a lot
of different meshes and that i kind of
got the impression that i should check
that it's using that same texture or not
and uh yeah i found the answer the
problem wasn't in the code but still
debugging kind of led to the answer
because i eliminated a bunch of things
and now to work on this lady
since uh we got that guy sorted out do
you see that flickering i mentioned that
last episode
but the far away flickering does anybody
know how to get rid of that it's after
about a thousand units or so it seems to
start happening pretty heavily
uh i don't think it happens so much on
the guys with lighting just the diffuse
only textures do that so maybe it's not
that big of a deal i don't know i'm not
gonna worry about it too much for now
although it does look a little
distracting he'll look better with
lighting on anyway
so yeah on to this fbx animated model
let's see if we can get her straightened
out
and go from there
i also notice my screen goes dark when i
hit the full screen button that's
not intentional it doesn't happen on my
screen it's only on recording so i
didn't realize until later
but yeah we're going to be walking
through this night shade now and
[Music]
and i guess i'll just do a break point
and do that thing i'm gonna have to save
that for the next episode this one's
gone on pretty long but
hopefully uh you've enjoyed the episode
alright see you next one peace out
[Music]
[Music]
you